ed miliband thanks very much indeed for
joining us this afternoon we really
appreciate it now labour has said today
that it's promising to spend an extra 28
billion pounds a year for a decade to
make the economy more green now that's a
huge amount of money to borrow just how
affordable is it when the government's
already borrowed record amounts to deal
with the pandemic
it is absolutely affordable and you know
the unaffordable choice is not to invest
because if we don't invest in tackling
the climate crisis we will store up
massive costs for the future for future
generations as they have to cope with
the appalling consequences of climate
change and if we do make these
investments and i was talking about this
yesterday in relation to the steel
industry it can create hundreds of
thousands if not millions of jobs across
our country
in helping to to build the economy of
the future in our manufacturing industry
in creating the green spaces that we
need retrofitting and insulating homes
this is about the economy of the future
it's absolutely the right thing to do
it's what joe biden president biden is
seeking to do in the united states i
think it's a bold imaginative and really
important move that rachel reeves has
announced today well let's talk a little
bit more about the money because
yesterday you announced three billion
pounds for the steel industry to
decarbonize that particular industry
which may be great for the planet but
there is a price to pay isn't there
people already facing higher taxes under
labour they'd have to go up even more
wouldn't they
well no what we're saying is it's right
to borrow to invest so take the steel
industry really important industry it's
a strategic industry for our national
security it's the foundation of our
manufacturing industry the best
estimates are it will cost six billion
to make this industry a green industry
because at the moment it's responsible
for more than 10 percent of our
manufacturing emissions now we could
decide not to have a steel industry
which means that tens of thousands of
people will lose their jobs all we can
decide as the choice labor's made to do
a partnership with the private sector to
invest for the future as other countries
are doing and we can have a clean green
steel industry and i think that's the
right choice it's the right choice for
our communities it's the right choice
for our economy and it means we don't
end up relying on imported steel from
countries like china
but ultimately we will have to pay for
it and also it can't happen overnight
can it decarbonizing a whole industry
may be the right thing to do but we have
to take it very delicately the same as
transitioning out of fossil fuel
industries or jobs will go there are so
many jobs tied up in these industries
well you are right about that definitely
and you know i think what's important
from labor um this week is it's about a
plan for the future it's about a
long-term plan and goodness knows when
we see some of the chaos that this
government is presiding over our country
needs a long-term plan you're right it's
not going to happen overnight it's a
decade-long plan it's a decade-long plan
that rachel reeves has announced today
it's the same that i had announced
yesterday
in relation to steel to the steel
industry and it's about working with
business we have many great businesses
in our country and that you know what
they're crying out for i see this as
shadow business and energy secretary
they're crying out for a sense of a plan
they're crying out for a sense of a
framework and a sense of certainty and
that's what labor is providing well yes
and the government says it's got its own
ten point plan of course and what about
cop 26 which the uk is hosting
we've heard today that the australian
prime minister says he may not attend we
don't know if the chinese premier will
be there how important is it that the
world leaders show up and how would you
go about persuading them to attend
well i think it's very very worrying
that that is happening and that you've
got world leaders not not potentially
not coming look i'm afraid to say the
government hasn't taken this summit with
nearly the seriousness that it deserves
and we've seen a series of missteps from
the government cutting overseas aid
which has made vulnerable countries
think that we are not serious about
helping them to make the transition not
having a green recovery here at home
telling other countries to power past
coal but flirting with a new coal mine
ourselves i'm afraid time is very short
and this is a summit in peril now what
does the government needs to need to do
it needs to deliver for vulnerable
countries that ten years ago we promised
to help those vulnerable countries make
the adaptation to climate change we've
still not delivered the finance they
need to deliver on that they need to
have no quarter with with giving a free
pass to countries like australia if
they're not going to face up to their
climate commitments we need to say to
them you've got to face up to their
climate commitments we've just done a
trade deal with them where we allowed
them to drop their climate commitments
and crucially we've got to deliver a
green recovery here at home the prime
minister has got to take this much much
more seriously we need all the senior
members of government applying
themselves to this in a way they frankly
haven't before you say that and yet they
would say we've got world-beating
targets for getting down our carbon
emissions they would say we've announced
an end to the sale of petrol and diesel
cars by 2030 10 years ahead of schedule
they'll talk about promising to
quadruple the amount of offshore wind
capacity within a decade they would say
they're doing their bit
well what they've done is they've
announced targets which you're right are
internationally very respectable and i
say to them that's a good it's good that
they've done that the problem is there
is a yawning chasm between the targets
and the delivery because they're not
delivering you know take this issue of
retrofitting or insulating homes we're
facing a gas price crisis
what could we have done to have avoided
this if we'd insulated our homes we
could have cut gas demand by something
by up to 25 in people's homes and
created lower bills and lower carbon
emissions but but year after year we've
been saying to government take these
measures these could create jobs
we could
help families and they haven't done that
so so i agree with you actually
internationally we're doing okay in
terms of the targets but we've got to
deliver and the announcement that labour
has made today this investment
announcement is exactly what i hope
government does frankly so that we can
deliver our promises to the british
people on the climate crisis
ed miliband thanks very much indeed
thank you